[Musique]
bienvenue à bibliothèque micis c'est à
la fois de l'histoire et de l'actualité
du passé et du présent le 30e
anniversaire du DI mai 1981 le 10 mai de
cette année-là est d'abord un
aboutissement pas seulement pour
François miteran mais pour ceux qui
attendaient une alternance qui n'avait
pas eu lieu depuis 23 ans un
aboutissement et un commencement pour
bibliothèque micis vous entendrez le
principal intéressé bien sûr François
mitteran et des acteurs de l'époque qui
vont témoigner et je comment savez-vous
catheriner parce que vous connaissez
bien toute cette période de la vie
politique vous l'avez commenté à
l'époque pour Europe 1 et vous aviez
publié deux livres en 1987 les SEP
mitérans et d'abord en 1984 le noir et
le rouge c'est un livre choc qui avait
dénoté avec la fureur tonton maniaque
qui
commençait à partir de quel moment vous
avez senti la l'odeur de la défaite de
la droite oh je dirais un ou deux mois
avant l'échéance parce qu'on sentait
bien qu'il y avait des réticences dans
l'électoragouist qui s'exprimait à
travers les députés à l'Assemblée
nationale et il y avait un bruit comme
ça qu'ils accréditaent comme quoi si
mitéran était élu et bien dans le fond
il reviendra au pouvoir 3 mois après
parce que s'il y avait soit le président
gardait la même assemblée donc la
majorité était à droite soit il
dissolvait que les les Français se
ressaisiraient et se redonneraient la
enfin remettrait la droite au pouvoir et
c'était des grandes voies de la droite
qui le dis c'était Charles pascoy
Jacques Chirac alors je ne sais pas s'il
le croyait vraiment tous les cas c'est
l'idée qui était propagée à l'époque
peut-être ils avaient contribué au
résultat peut-être Hubert Vedrine
aujourd'hui président de l'Institut
mitéran auteur de différents livres
formidables sur cette époque pas
seulement François Mitterant un dessin
un destin dont on avait parlé qui est
publié par les é iition galimar dans la
collection descouvertes Galar galimar
c'est très bien euh pendant combien
d'années vous avez travaillé au côté
vraiment très proche de françiséran bah
très proche c'est pendant la présidence
avant j'étais un collaborateur
occasionnel extérieur à partir de
janvier 1973 au total ayant fini mon
stage de Len j'avais été le voir et donc
je Travis j'ai même mé une petite main
dans la campagne de 74 beaucoup moins
important que jacqu et d'autres mais
j'étais déjà là dans le processus mais
au total au total ça fait
euh 22 ans mais donc don les 14 de
l'Élysée jacquelan guilus ministre de la
Culture compagnon de François miteran
vous publiez au seuil un livre qui va
intéresser fragment de vie partagé et
qui commence avant 1981 pierre Fabier
vous publié au Seuil 10 jours en mai
après les quatre volumes sur la décennie
militérant que vous avez publié il y a
quelques années vous étiez journaliste
accrédité à la FP de 801 à 95 et vous
avez couvert pratiquement les deux sepat
de François miteran
quand avez-vous senti vous comment dire
le parfum de la victoire pour la
première fois j'allais dire un petit peu
comme tous les observateurs à l'époque
jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre de 80
les sondages donné jiscar gagnant pas de
beaucoup mais le donnerit gagnant et à
partir de janvier-février 1981 les
sondages ont commencé à tourner et
laisser laisser entrevoir une victoire
possible de de François miteran et j'ai
le souvenir même d'un voyage avec
miteran en Chine avant même l'élection
présidentielle en février 81 et on
parlait comme ça tous les soirs avec lui
à l'heure du dîner et il nous répétait à
chaque fois cette fois je vais gagner
cette fois c'est fait la victoire est au
bout du
fusil quand pour la première fois
avez-vous senti le parfum de la victoire
même question assez tard parce que moi j
avais cru un peu en
74 et en fait après je n'osais pas y
croire et d'ailleurs j'étais à chin
parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais député suppléant premère
circonscription de ne ver à la demande
de François mitteran et donc après avoir
été à Saint le G desvges j'avais été à
chatouchinon il y avait cette petite
foule qui était assemblée face à
l'Auberge du Vieux Morvant avant que
circulle les premiers sondages sortis
des journes ouais mais c'était par
superstition quoi mais vous pensiez que
ça arrivait j'osais pas le croire je le
souhaitais ardemment j'arrivais pas à y
croire en fait et vous jacquelan je suis
un peu comme Hubert je n'osais pas le
croire je l'espérais évidemment
intensément et
euh j'étais tellement comme utre
impatient angoissé que une fois la
campagne terminée le vendredi un grand
meeting à Nantes avec ma femme nous nous
sommes précipité à villeorban au TNP
pour assister à la présentation de
pergunt mis en scène par Patrice Cherot
pour oublier et vous arriviez à oublier
vous allez nous faire très difficilement
et où étiez-vous le 10 mA r fino ou
Catherine le 10 mai j'étais le soir à
Antenne 2 où vous officiez avec Étienne
moujot d'abord je je sais absolument pas
ce que j'y faisais j'ai aucun souvenir
en tous les cas je sais que une
demi-heure avant le résultat je scrutais
dans vos visages vous deux si je pouvais
apercevoir à travers vos regards quelque
chose qui m'aurait indiqué qu' avait
gagné et puis quand le dessin est apparu
sur vous savez à 20h et que j'ai vu se
dérouler le le le la la silhouette enfin
on dit pas la silhouette de la tête et
moi j'ai cru que c'était giscar et puis
voilà ouais ouais et vous Jean-Pierre on
a envie de vous poser la même question
j'étais à l'anttenne avec Étienne moujot
c'est lui comme directeur de la
rédaction de R 1 et moi comme celle de
anenne 2 qui avion insisté pour avoir
ces deux visages qui jusqu'au dernier
moment créaient le le suspens quand
est-ce que vous avez euh à 18h25
quelques minutes avant généralement je
pose les questions mais c'est bien je
réponds volontier je réponds volontiers
à 18h25 et euh c'était vraiment le début
d'une alternance historique et il
fallait avoir les Ners pour être là et
je me souviens avoir dit à Étienne
Moujotte on était assez calme euh on ne
rit pas trop on pensera que déjà comme
d'autres nous sommes convertis en
quelques heures et nous pleurons pas ou
ne faisons pas des des des têtes
allongées pour pas qu'on croit que nous
pleurons déjà giscar qui parle la
neutralité l'impartialité mais
apparemment euh selon sa sa ses choix
politiques et idéologiques on a
interprété notre comportement
différemment pierre Favier je je me
trouv à Château Chinon j'étais à
l'époque jeune reporter à la FP et je
couvrais le le vote de François mitteran
à ch au Cheon qu je le souvenir
effectivement comme Hubert vedr de cette
foule rassemblée devant l'hôtel du vieux
Morvant et dans mitteran surtout
extrêmement calme et maître de lui tout
au long de cette
journée oui il était totalement même
impavide quoi et les gens autour de lui
s'agiter téléphoner dans tous les sens
et lui resta d'un calme étonnant il ne
bronchait pas et quand il va prendre la
victoire qu'est-ce qu'il
dit il a dit à pluss quelle histoire
quelle histoire mais il l'a redit le
soir en nous retrouvant r fer
qu l' hisisttoire la formule est belle
parce que elle dit à la fois ce que vous
disiez au début c'est l'aboutissement
d'une longue marche d'une longue
traversée 23 ans d'opposition et le
commencement d'une autre histoire la
gauche au pouvoir moi j'ai entendu à peu
près mais à Mo un tout petit peu
diffiant après sa déclaration dans la
mirriie de chatouinon il repart par un
couloir adjacent où j'étais avec ma
femme il vient vers nous il dit vous
vous rendez compte de ce qui nous arrive
comme ça c'est un peu la variante de
quelle hisoire mais oui aussi cette
formule il vaut mieux que ce soit comme
ça qu'autrement quoi c'est ce qu'il
avait répondu à à Jean glavani qui lui
annoncé lui aussi et vous vous racontez
que chacun se demande à ce momentlà quel
rôle vais-je jouer quel poste va-t-il
m'attribuer mais personne se demande
comment le pays va être gouverné oui
très vite justement dès le soir du 10
mai j'ai eu des beaucoup de témoignages
sur la soirée du 10 mai rue de Solferino
et deux trois des des témoins qui me
racontent cette soirée à attendre que
miteran revienne de château chinan se
souviennent de des uns et des autres qui
disaient mais qu'est-ce que je vais
faire quelle va être ma place dans le
dispositif mitérandien est-ce que je
vais aller au gouvernement est-ce que je
Seris à l'Élysée beaucoup s'interrogent
sur leur propre devenir et vous
correspondant de la FP qui assist au
résultat vous êtes heureux aussi oui
parce que bon pourquoi le cacher j'étais
plutôt heureux de voir la la victoire de
mitteran pense vous n'avez jamais pu
résister à François mitteran et un
certain mitterandisme même pendant les
14 ans je n'ai pas eu besoin de lui
résister je n'ai pas eu à lui résister
quoi à dire vrai mais je ne cache pas
que j'avais effectivement de de l'estime
une certaine joie ce soir là le di mai a
été précédé de plusieurs défaites du
candidat François miteran face à de
Gaulle en 1965 face à Valérie
giscardessin en 74 en 78 il y av eu les
élections législatives et la victoire
vous l'aviez frôé presque mais c'était
la défaite en 78 au point que certains
le croyaient fini archaïque comme disait
quelqu'un et lui préférait jusqu'en
octobre 80 octobre novembre Michel
Rocard qui mieux que Valéri Giscard
desestin pour parler des deux débats qui
ont marqué les
mémoires c'est totalement improvisé
totalement improvisé d'abord j'avais
très peu préparé ce débat j'avais
rassemblé quelques statistiques chiffres
et mais très peu préparé et ensuite
c'est simplement quand j'ai vu mit Teran
avec son air que vous avez observé vous
par la suite pas son air à la fois à la
fois
mielleux et bon énumérer la liste des
gens malheureux en Franceon
énuméré la liste des g ça suffit vous
allez pas faire mais n pas le monopole
du cœur moi je les connais aussi je vais
m'occuper d'eux et cetera donc c'était
une réaction instinctive et qu'a
estomaqué parce qu'il était on était
prêt l' pas très loin et je l'ai vu ah
oui il a reçu un coup l'estomac en fait
et alors en 1981 je sais pas si vous
êtes préparé pour le 2ème débat vous
vous prenez vous semblez prendre de haut
votre rival et il vous répond vous ne
lui ferez pas le coup 74 que s'il était
l'homme du passé vous étiez l'homme du
passif vous vous souvenez et ça ça vous
avait atteint aussi ça ça doit être une
formule de ces Gal fr mais sur le moment
ça fait un choc non ce qui m'avait
atteint c'est qu'il avait fait enfin
mais je vois pas pourquoi on parle de ça
mais je vous parler de mon livre bon
allons-y non ce que je n'ai pas aimé
très franchement parce que c'est un
homme qui était intéressant nous avons
des vrais rapport il avait cette idée
curieuse d'ailleurs euh quand n nous
voyons qui était de dire mais au fond
nous sommes les deux seuls à avoir
exercé le pouvoir en France nous sommes
les deux seuls qui pouvons parler en se
comprenant l'un l'autre et dans le débat
il a été au total assez
correct sauf la fin parce que le tirage
au sort lui avait donné la dernière
intervention et dans sa dernière
intervention il était venimeux venimeux
en ramassant tout ce qu' pouvit trouver
comme attaque de toute espèce auquel je
pouvais pas répondre donc je me suis
quand même été choqué par cette conduite
alors père Favier vous racontez les 10
jours presque heure par heure les 10
jours entre le 10 mai et le 21 mai le
jour de l'inallationinstallation
l'installation à l'Élysée et le 10 11
mai vous racontez quelque chose que
j'ignorais complètement et qui vous a
été raconté par Katheline even
elle va dans son journal Le Nouvel
Observateur il y avait jeandiiel Gilles
martinet et Michel Rocard et qu'est-ce
que dit Rocard quand elle
arrive elle arrive elle vient de
reportage
elle rentre au journal et elle trouve
effectivement Jean Danel rard qui sont
consternés par la victoire de mitteran
et qu'il dit apparemment rard dit ce qu'
va nous mettre des communistes au
gouvernement c'est ce con ce ça ça va
nous installer des va faire venir des
communistes au gouvernement et
Jean-Daniel c'est pas possible il fera
pas ça il fera pas or il le fera ilait
dit il leou et chez le communiste
c'était le même climat de veill funèbre
érant président alors qu'ils avaient
donné et c'est ce que répète Pierre
Juquin j'ai entendu à peu près la même
chose à un moment donné de
marchire de voter giscar d'aller jusqu'à
voter giscar pour empêcher mitteran de
gagner et le soir de la victoire au di
place Colonel Fabien au siège du Parti
communiste les responsables les
dirigeants du parti sont consternés et
Gaston Plissonnier qui est un vieux
Cassique du parti un stalinien de on va
quand même faire sembl parce qu'il la
presse voilàisson vient et dit il
faudrait qu'on qu'on sourit un petit peu
qu'on se montre joyeux car mit vient de
gagner les journalistes sont là vous
saviez ça et Jin à la Bastille qui monte
sur l'estrade avec rard et qui dit je
suis heureux je suis heureux ça c'est
ouis vous saviez j Basti oui je le
savais
puisque je ne sais pas con vous savez la
façon de parler de de rard est parfois
un peu familière disons
mais ne le Savit pas il aura l'occasion
de se rattraper lui aussi à l'égard de
Michel on peut le dire
les communistes ont compris trop tard
que miteran était plus fort qu'eux et
que miteran avait une emprise
extrainaire sur l'électorat communiste
donc l'appareil ESS de freiner parce
qu'ils ont vu qu'ils allaient être
dévorés par la suite trop tard alors il
y a en tout cas en germe les tensions et
les désaccords qui viendront les années
suivantes à la fois avec les communistes
et avec Michel Rocard qui sera quand
même son premier ministre lors du début
du 2è septenard quand prévient-il pierre
merois qu'il va le nommer à matigon
premier Premier ministre du
septenamerran pierre monrois le confit
lui-même ah excellent souir ça c'est le
dim vous voyez je suis dans la voiture
là je sors de l'Élysée et nous avons
remonté les ChampsÉlysées alors quand on
sera sur les Champs-Élysées il y avait
toute une foule en liesse et il y avait
François Mitterant d'ailleurs qui n'est
pas resté assis qui s'est mis debout
dans sa voiture et qui naturellement
saluait la foule quoi et moi j'étais à
côté de lui je saluais aussi euh je je
voulais avoir un mot de lui parce que je
savais qu'à 16h ce jour-là là il était
midi ce jour-là j'allais rencontré bon
voilà le le gouverneur de la Banque de
France il faudrait prendre la décision
en ce qui concerne une dévaluation
possible on avait décidé de ne pas faire
de dévaluation le jour tout de même où
président de la République salue sa sa
victoire avec le peuple qui est
rassemblé sur l'une des plus belles
avenues de France et du monde j'essayis
de lui parler mais c'est impossible
c'est impossible finalement on n pas eu
de communication il était ailleurs il
était dans la joie de d'être élu
président de la République d'être
investi d'être au milieu du peuple
français on se laisse aller à la joie à
répondre au vivad de la foule bon à
laavir nombreuse rassemblé et heureuse
le le di mai était sera pour moi pour
bien d'autres quelque chose d'absolument
exceptionnel il y en a qui ont entendu
23 ans ce jour-là que la gauche Vienne
au pouvoir on a pleuré quoi dans les
chaumières on va pas seulement pleurer
je crois qu'on a goûté aussi ouvert des
des bouteilles de champagne et cetera
vous savez pour ceux qui étaient des des
militants cou et pour ceux qui avaient
voté socialistes et qui jamais n nous
avvez vu sur les marches du palais je
parle de
l'Élysée à matigon bah pour cela c'était
quand même pas un jour comme les autres
la gauche arrive au pouvoir on a un
président de la République et on espère
que ça va durer ah ben just justement
pierre mais exprime bien la crainte de
l'époque apparemment on se posait pas la
question d'un éventuel deuxèe sepat de
François mitteran hein mais surtout de
savoir si vous alliez traverser les
épreuves euh alors que la droite qui
avait été sonnée commençait assez vite à
se requinquer c'est vrai que que la
gauche était hantée par le souvenir de
d'expérience entre guillemets au pouvoir
relativement courte le Front populaire
quelques mois finalement la libération
était- la gauche même une question qui
se pose le gouvernement pierre France
quelques mois donc ce sentiment que l'on
pouvait éprouver d'un risque euh d'être
déstabilisé n'était pas absent en même
temps il y avait ce qu'on a appelé
l'état de grâce donc tous les
ingrédients étaient réunis pour agir
vite fort avec détermination chaque
heure comptait autant qu'une semaine
chaque heure chaque jour il fallait les
rendre utille comme dit Pierre Favier
chque j dès le départ biterant à la
volonté d'installer la gauche dans la
durée il sait qu'auparavant ça a été de
brèves fractures de l'histoire comme il
dit et là dès le 11 mai 81 il Pr par les
législatives avec les responsables de
son parti il leur demande négocier avec
les communistes il veut absolument que
la gauche dure au moins un une mandature
oui oui mais entre le moment où il le
décide il a il y a quand même le
suspense de ce qui va arriver et vous
racontez un peu dans le livre pendant
ces jours-là un certain desordre deux
groupes qui font à peu près en même
temps les mêmes gestes et cetera il
vousont raconter comment lui là Hubert
Vedrine a passé sa nuit du 11 au 12 je
sais pas si c'est vrai dans sa cuisine a
remercier le pape le président des
États-Unis a envoyé des messages
télégram de remerciement et de T j'avais
pas l'habitude avant hein je me
demandais comment on écrit au pape par
exemple entre autres et comment on
trouve la formule j'ai trouvé ouais et
et mais moi j'ai pas du tout vécu dans
ce climat de d'inquiétude dès le début
peut-être parce que j'étais dans une
bulle j'ai 34 ans leslis on était très
nombreux à être avir 30 35 ans même s'il
y avait aussi Roussely le gar grosou
tout ça pour pour moi je trouvais ça
hurissant les socialistes qui
s'inquiétaient de la durée sans parler
de ce qui qui avait peur en comparant au
Chili ça paraissit AB lui-même se
préoccupa pour lui c'était une obsession
les législatives est
gagn gagné surtout l'idée tout ça n'est
pas contradictoire c'est l'idée que
c'est ce sera plus facile d maintenant
d'agir de d'adopter telle loi que le
jour où l'impopularité inévitablement
viendra à plusieurs reprises pendant ces
10 jours il dit à Jacques Atali on va
devenir très vite impopulaire il faut
gagner les législatives et nous aons 5
ans et la duré pour pour travailler
alors et quels sont les premiers soucis
les premières décisions à prendre en
urgence d'abord justement répondre à la
dévaluation parce que les caisses de la
Banque de France se vident et la la la
la question de la dévaluation a été
tranchée assez vite dans le dans le mois
qui a suivi avant même l'entrée à
l'Élysée le président avait demandé à
Pierre bergovois accompagnie de Claude
de kimouia et de moi de faire le tour
des ambassadeurs arabes importants de
Paris par qu' officiellement il y avait
des questions sur le proche orient enfin
les positions de miterant étaient
inattaquables et en fait c'était les
communistes qui les inquiétaient pour
leurs investissement en France donc il y
avait un risque sur la monnaie il av
cinte que les Arabes retirent le leur
fonds investis en France le premier
voyage de Merran était en Arabie
saoudite et en
1981 j'avais décidé de que la télévision
c'éit à l'époque AN2 si je me souviens
bien diffuse intégralement la journée de
la passation des pouvoirs et et en même
temps le le le jour du Panthéon et
mitéran vainqueur c'est vous qui aviez
organisé la visite au Panthéon avec
Serge moiti Roger annin qui avait choisi
le panéon Christian du pavillon
Christian du pavillon qui va être votre
collaborateur qui va être un homme de
grande imagination ou oui et de grande
créativité non c'est
V je l'ai vu puis vous m l'avez dit
alors qui qui a eu l'idée du P je ne
peux pas dire le jour exacte peut-être
le surlendemain du 10 mai François mit
m'a fait venir dans sont pisonnier vous
le voyez le 12 mai le 12 mai il lit
beaucoup plus que
moi véritable historiographe mais pas
officiel un enquêteurquteur
V vous continuez à préciser chaque fois
qu'il le faut alors
12 y av Andr Roussel si ma mémoire est
bonne et après le déjeuner vous allez
jusqu' sous les toi exactement et il me
dit j'aimerais que vous puissiez avec
André rouss vous préoccuper de la
journée d' investiture dont dont la date
n'était pas établie parce que le pantéon
qui ah le pantéon alors c'est je crois
que c'est je crois que c'est lui je
crois que c'est lui on a évoqué le
quartier latin parce que quartier
symbolique de la Genève de la culture de
l'ouverture au monde bon ça été une un
échange été rapide quelques et les
Français s'en souviennent les les gens
de cette génération là et les et les
plus jeunes quel méthode de travail
François
miteran Jacques langraaconte vous aussi
pierre Mo va le dire faut en parler à
partir de l'installation à l'Élysée que
moi j'ai pas de témoignage direct avant
parce que pendant la période de
l'antenne présidentielle c'est surtout
Berry goovois qui va avec des parafeurs
ou des l'élyisée l'Élysée c'est
intéressant parce que c à la fois très
organisé et subtile un peu complexe ce
qui est clair c'est qu'assz vite on sait
que c'est Pierre berovoie qui sera
Secrétaire Général puis on sait
qu'athalie sera conseiller spécial et
pour le reste la façon dont après dans
un second temps il semblerait que ce
soit d'ailleurs n pas dans les détails
nous perdons pas dans les détails parce
qu'il y aurait tellement de choses à
dire sur 14 détail très riches ouais et
alors après il y a ce que j'ai appelé
moi dans un de mes livre sur un ton un
peu malicieux l'organigramme en écaille
c'est-à-dire que chacun un rôle mais en
même temps il marche un peu sur les
pieds d'un autre et d'autres lui
marchent un peu sur les pieds et c'était
un système à la fois efficace miton
voulait avoir des collaborateurs
compétents et fiables et capable et en
même temps il voulait pas que ça
s'enferme dans un système bureaucratique
stagnant est-ce qu'il réunissait tout le
monde chaque fois jamais jamais une fois
moi je le d'une réunion qui est le le le
jour où elmou Schmith est venu voir memp
pour la première fois c'est tout à fait
au début après il a gardé dans son
bureau ce qui était là donc il y avait
rousle il y avait bergovois il y avait
vosel je crois glavani des gens comme ça
il a fait une description de la façon
dont ça allait marcher qui était assez
étrange en fait parce que c'était jamais
en terme de compéten bien définie donc
les ceci mais avec
tel non mais la présentation devant ce
petit groupe de 10 personnes c'est
impossible d'en déduire un organigramme
clair h c'est venu petit à petit par la
suite dans le domaine international par
exemple je suis devenu après le consil
diplomatique mais en tenant compte d'une
dizaine d'autres personnes qui avaient
leur moi à dire et dans les autres
domaines c'était pareil et berovo joue
un rôle clé hein là-dessus parce qu'il
était quand même très intelligent très
clair très précis très rapide
extrêmement organisé donc il a appris à
travailler tout ce petit monde pour que
la machine se mette à et Pierre Mor
lui-même qui a été premier ministre
raconte dès le début comment ça ça a
fonctionné avec le président de la
République mitéran dans le bureau de
l'Élysée pierre Mor la Réunion
traditionnelle alors je peux vous dire
que ça alors il y en a eu des centaines
al des réunions comme ça il est dans son
bureau il est dans son fauteuil et moi
je suis dans un fauteuil en face de lui
et nous bavardons car c'est une
caractéristique avec François mitteran
on narrive pas avec des des dossiers
avec des collaborateurs et cetera on
parle on parle on connaît bien nos
dossiers on parle vous le mettez au
présent c'est extraordinaire je veux le
faire avancer je veux le faire avancer
sur un sujet il veut me faire avancer
sur un autre sujet si je résiste VO ça
la semaine suivante voilà en fait de lui
bon ça a été une très longue
conversation sur nos problème d'État
pour les faire progresser c'est ça qui
était extraordinaire et avant même qu'il
devienne président de la République mais
c'est même arrivé comme président de la
République on allait faire un petit tour
dans Paris aimait ça on se promenait de
long de la scène on allait au
palaisroyal et voilà et est-ce que c'est
vrai que quand vous vous êtes séparé au
bout de ces 38 mois 1000 jours c'est par
conséqu voilà Laurent Fabius va vous
succéder vous êtes c'est un petit
déjeuner ou un déjeuner on raconte vous
étiez pas
quit on s'ae on s'aime presque au bord
des larmes c'est vrai oui vrai c'est
vrai oui on ne parle plus de ces
problèmes SAF vous savez partez ouais
sauf qu'on est remonté dans son bureau
et que là on s'est quitté il a rien su
me dire et moi je n'ai rien su lui dire
voilà nous étions et vous n'étiez plus
prier ministre ému voilà et je suis
sorti de son bureau j'étais plus premier
min ministre et lui est sorti de son
bureau en disant je crois à Bianco ça a
été un des moments les plus pénibles de
ma vie
uber Vedrine l'organisation il voulait à
la fois que ça fonctionne très bien très
vite très fiablement de façon très
professionnelle et en même temps que
jamais le système éliséen ou
gouvernemental n'empêche une idée
nouvelle d'arriver jusqu'à lui ou une
personnalité nouvelle de s'exprimer donc
il fallait combiner les larmes de la
séparation dont parlait pierre moi ont
cédé une amitié une fidélité qui vont
demeurer tout le temps puis dirit
d'entendre encore Pierre MAA aujourd'hui
parmi les fidèles il y avait Jacques
atalier auteur de de gros volumes de ver
btime parfois controversé mais en tout
cas passionnant de témoignages sur
François miteran Robert balenter Roland
Duma vous Jacques Lang vous Hubert
vetterine et Michel charas qui sera un
des inventeurs des bons et des mauvais
coups politiques et qui s'occupera de
François mitteran à sa mort avec André
housousle vous étiez avec nous lors d'un
précédent bibliothèque micis avec Michel
charass et Monique spber je sais pas si
vous en souvenez vous finissiez par
transformer François mitteran en une
sorte de Saint laïque écoutez-vous c'est
pas un sain les sains d'après ce que je
sais du Vatican ils sont inéressant
d'avoir par Michel charas quelques
défauts de François
miteran
écoutezjà à l'époque il en avait pas
Jean-Pierre il était un homme comme tout
le monde et il avait forcément des
défauts bon on passait pas notre temps à
relever ses
défauts non vient pas comme ça à
l'idée quelis quand avait des choses
bonne question pardon lui arrivait-il de
mentir tout être humain oui écoutez même
chose che on le disait on le disait
certains le disaient c'est détracteurs
le disaiit il montait pas vraiment il
bon mais il avait quelquefis par exemple
tendance à reprocher à d'autres des
choses qu'il avait qu'il avait quasiment
fait lui-même ou alors lorsqu'il avait
envie de s'en prend maaise FO se moi je
me souviens d'un sommet je crois que
c'était dans l'heure àvreux un sommet
franco-anglais où les Anglais étaient en
retard il pleuvaient il pleuvaient il
faisait un temps épouvantable et où il
aventueulé le chef du protocole on lu
dis en plus il fait mauvais h comme
disais non seulement ils sont en retard
en plus il fait mauvais le chef du
protocole n pas responsable quand même
du mauvais temps
bon une citation sans vouloir me vanter
il fait quand même rudement beau
aujourd'huiou
vous vous souvenez de ce moment-l hein
euh pour je souven de la citation finale
oui pour la démystification on peut se
rassuré il y a Catherine vous avez fait
le job au canon en 1984 non pas du tout
no et le rouge mais c'est pas du tout on
a dit que c'était au canon vous ça
prouve que vous n'avez peut-être pas lu
mon Liv moi j'ai j'ai raconté j'ai j'ai
raconté vous avez interrogé à Europe sur
le livre j'ai raconté j'ai raconté
l'histoire d'un homme moi je me suis pas
dit quand j'ai commencé l'histoire et
cette enquête formidable sur un homme
qui a été dans l'histoire pendant 50 ans
je me suis pas dit qu'est-ce que je vais
faire pour le démolir moi je je suis je
voulais pas vivre avec un homme pendant
7 ans que je ne connaissais pas je ne le
connaissais pas je suis partie à sa
rencontre et je peux vous dire que quand
j'ai commencé le l'enquête sur l'enfant
sur le milieu provincial catholique moi
j'ai d'autant plus aimé je me suis dit
je pars pour uneagéographie parce que je
retrouvais un peu mon milieu d'origine
si vous voulez et puis après j'ai vu
comment s'est construit le personnage
avec tout ce qu'il y a de rourie de
volteface de grande habilité de grands
talent mais puis je veux dire un homme
qui a été qui a fait toute l'histoire la
4e République puis la l'opposition à de
Gaulle puis après l'arrivé au pouvoir
non c'est je veux dire c'est un homme je
crois que c'est une des biographies les
plus riches qu'on ait pu rencontrer il y
avait de Gaul il y avait lui d'une
certaine manière vous voulez dire une ve
plus riche oui oui voilà une ville une
viille poque le noir et le rouge en tout
cas avaiit provoqué un un certain
plaisir même fort à droite qui relevait
la tête et puis un électrochoc à gauche
chez l'imitérandiste
euh qui jusqu'à présent
prouver applaudissez admirer n'est-ce
pas jaccland absolument vous
reconnaissez à cette époque mais oui
bien sûr je ne la Renis pas mais vous
vous rappelez l'époque vous disiez à la
lumière oui
faut non non non mais je ne je ne je ne
j'assume pleinement mais simplement
c'est c'est c'est le contexte et et
cette fameuse formule qu'on qu'on qu'on
cite en permanence ah oui quand on a il
faut dire que quand quand on a l'acteur
principal autour de so profite oui non
elle signifiait enfin c'est ainsi que je
l'avais interpréter que ça s'adressait
surtout aux Français qui ont tue à ce
moment-là le l'audace le courage de
franchir la ligne de de de de choisir
l'alternance et pendant si longtemps le
le
pays vivait sous sur l'idée que la
droite était au pouvoir pour l'éternité
donc il fallait vaincre cette
malédiction pour qu'en France
l'alternance enfin V la lumière oui non
pas la lumière la lumière d'une démocra
Grae normale voilà c'était la première
alternance quand même depuis
1958 la droite avait gouverné bon pour
la première fois la gauche arrivé au
pouvoir donc je veux pas justifier les
propos de langue mais on peut comprendre
le contexte de l'époque effectivement
mais il a pas changé il a pas changé
dans son livre Jacques land dit je le
crois mitéran éternel
immortel non comme un dieu vivant mais
comme un homme capable de voler au dieu
le secret de la vie voyez restez fidèle
vous extrayez les choses ah benah oui si
à propos de de de la mort et vous dites
je rêve d'une vie de 1000 ans
oui quoi vous rêve vous rêvez d'une vie
de 3 jours non mais le plus long
possible sans atteindre 1000 ans et j'ai
jamais prétendu à une immortalité
fut-elle laïque et républicaine comme je
vrais dire un mot sur le livre de
Catherine ne moi j'ai trouvé à l'époque
que tous les livres qui montraient la
complexité de mitteran sa richesse sa
diversité la diversité du parcours était
bon pour lui en fait et montré que
c'était autre chose qu'un simplement le
chef de la moitié de ce pays je pense
que on a vu dans d'autres épisodes de sa
de sa présidence et par la réélection de
88 à quel point il était capable
évidemment d'être le grand leader de la
gauche il n'a pas été remplacé jusqu'ici
sur ce plan mais on y comprenit tout le
reste du pays est-ce que ce Liv de
livre on y apprend beaucoup de choses
prement sur l'enfance la famille
l'adolescence estce que est très très
vrai finalement c'est pas un livre style
en fait
finement pr été prê comme ça mais moi
j'ai fait un travail de journaliste je
suis partie sans a prior plus tard plus
tard plus tard après François mitan dira
lui-même sur un ton sarcastique et drôle
ce qu'il pensait des livre qui vers la
fin ne cessait de pleuvoir pas comme le
vôtre mais cette fois pour le critiquer
François
mitî comme comme livre ou
ou je fais leur fortune quand même ce
sont mes
pauvres
m ensite
dans c'est vrai que à chaque jour on
peut
voiracharnement
vraianis juif Françis est catholique
Françis mit Françis cette semaine c'est
les fr quand vous découvrez les journaux
vous lisez pour savoir finalement do
plus important je
cro vous faites vendre
quoi
la haine la haine avvez-vous dit vous
pensez que vous arriverez un jour à
vaincre la haine même celle qui vous non
je n'y arriverai pas mais c'est comme
quand on a un grand projet de vie on
veut que sa vie soit belle et réussie et
la vie c'est comme un chemin qu'on a
devant soi on imagine à 20 ans c'est
cette route à 100 km de long comme le
parcours va être beau et puis à la
veille de mourir on se rend compte qu'on
a fait 150
m mais il vaut mieux les avoir fait que
de SRE arrêté au bas du du
faossé est-ce que vous pensez que quand
vous serez parti d'ici quand vous aurez
quitté ce palais ceux qui vous ont
détesté combattu parce qu'il vous a
détesté se calmeront et verront plus
justement où qu'il ils ils en voudront
d'autres parce que moi je serait plus
intéressant à ce moment-là et vous
pensez bien que ceuxl même vous verront
peut-être autrement parce qu'ils auront
d'autres chat à fouettter si je peux
dire sans doute oui pu ça égal vraiment
ça égal vous ne souonnez pas ma capacité
d'indifférence comment on
l'entretient des différence d'abord la
force de
l'habitude ensuite une certaine distance
par rapport à l'événement et peut-être
une certaine façon de mesurer
l'importance des choses il y a ce qui
est important et ce qui est nul et les
humeurs de Monsieur Intel ou de Monsieur
Intel les obvectif Monsieur Untel
Monsieur Untel mais ce sont des tout
petits bons
hommes on les entend parce qu'on est là
à Paris
dans un système un peu clos euh mais
regardez l'histoire du
monde tout ça ça pèse
pas dans l'histoire qu'est-ce qu'ils
seront ils auront répandu une rumeur qui
aura un peu altérer votre mémoire
pendant quelques temps et puisis
l'histoire des irad d'ailleurs moi aussi
bien il avait raison au t il a raison
mais en même temps se disant il n'est
pas totalement indifférent oui ou même
si le mot indifférent c'est profession
de foi qu'il pratique mais en même temps
on sait pour ceux qui l'ont fréquenté
qui qu'il avait quand même en
lui blessures l' difffférence c'est une
asè dans laquelle il faut tendre pas d'
arver CIS qu' près de 300 livres sur sur
lui ou sur l'époque mitéran quoi avec
les vôres et encore un peu plus beaucoup
de Liv début à la fin François miteran
fragment de vie partagée je l'ai dit aux
éditions de seuil miteran c'est un peu
l'éblouissement de votre vie c'est un
éblouissement de ma vie oui parce que ça
coïncide avec l'accomplissement de
choses auxquelles j'ai je croyais depuis
très longtemps c'est-à-dire une
transformation du paysage culturel du
pays une autre forme de démocratie donc
c'est vrai que nous av sont les les
années que j'ai eu le privilège et le
bonheur de partager avec lui sont des
années d'accomplissement de rêve de rêve
à la fois comme comme démocrate
professeur de droit amoureux de la
culture et dés désireux de changer les
chose et et chaque fois c'était oui à la
culture élitaire pour tous hein ce que
vous dites dans le livre non à
l'élitisme méprisant de quelques
privilégié la formule n'est pas mauvaise
ah ouais puisquelle est jalang elle doit
être bonne et vous racontez vos no
efforts encouragés par le Président de
la République en faveur des artistes et
de la création pour raconter ce qu'ont
été les grands travaux l'opéra la
bibliothèque le le Grand Louvre avec
Émile biiaazini et François mittiran qui
s'engageait comme un président
architecte sans lui et avec votre
tenacité ça n'aurait pas pu nîre puis la
la pyramide 2 pay et cetera et cetera
dans quel circonstances vous avez dit
non à à miteran mais un non musclé non
il y a eu bon disons que je je je suis
un obstiné un entêté un bagarur quand je
crois quelque chose h le sais d'ailleurs
un peu je l'ai parfois harcelé lui aussi
sur les questions budgettaires sur ceci
ou sur cela mais Fran lui-même est
autrement il n'aurait jamais réussi ce
qu'il a accompli était un homme entêté
et convaincu donc nous étions en N
constitu une sorte de couple assez
particulier 20 ans de différence deux
origines très très différentes et et
nous avons été pratiquement d'accord sur
tout parfois
simplement sans qu'on ait besoin de de
d'échanger formellement un assentiment
mais eu un sujet sur lequel j'ai été en
désaccord très profond avec lui c'est
lorsqu'il a décidé de créer cette 5è
chaîne privée qu'il voulait confier à
Berlusconi ça vous n'avez pas aimé pas
du tout il y a vous et on s'est bagarré
je me suis bagarré avec quelques autres
j'ai tenté de d'infléchir la décision
qui pu obtenir à la marge quelques
changement et François mitteran s'est
rendu compte que là on était au bord
d'une rupture et sachant l'affection que
que qui me relia à lui il m'adressa une
lettre que que je reproduis dans ce
livre une lettre manuscrite qui commence
par ces mots j'allais dire typiquement
myérandien cessons la guerre des nerf
cessons la guerre des N et il m'explique
ensuite en quoi j'ai tort en quoi il a
raison finalement nous étions à 2 mois
de législative et et j'ai naturellement
accepté et beaucoup de ce qui reste de
lui c'est aussi des décisions liées à la
culture soit vos décisions le prix du
livre les fêtes les fêtes de la musique
et tellement d'autres choses et certains
des grands travaux euh vous trouviez que
François mitterin avait une santé de
faire vous dites jamais de problème 7h
8h j'étais dans l'ignorance totale de du
mal qui qu'il était qui était en lui et
jusque jusqu'au moment de jusqu'à 92
disons bon moi j'enviais sa santé son
énergie sa combativité et la façon dont
il menait sa politique internationale ou
sa politique intérieur je ne savais rien
de cette ja dit si miteran avait voulu
aller si vite à l'automne 81 c'est parce
qu'il ne pensait pas vivre au-delà de
quelques mois vous ne saviez pas rien et
vous ah non moi je n'ai j'ai rien su de
tout ça disons avant d'être secrétaire
général c'est à peu près la même période
91- 92 et en plus j'ai fait le tour du
monde avec imérand dans 36 voyages que
j'organisais comme conseil diplomatique
tout le monde était sur les rotules
enfin sauf lui et vous connaissez secret
non pas du tout je le suivais comme
journaliste pendant toute cette période
la rumeur circulait qu'il était très
malade mais en réalité il travaillait et
fonctionnait et remplissait ses
fonctions comme quelqu'un qui était en
apparemment en bonne santé en tout cas
moi j'ai
plusis bonne santé il avait une énergie
de fer et dis bon c'est une question
évidemment difficile on dit il a raconté
des un mensonge sans doute sans doute
oui
l'erreur je le dis très franchement
c'est pas politiquement incorrect
peut-être mais je trouve
absurde de de de publier un bultain
santé c'est absurde parce que c'est quoi
la santé c'est pas seulement le nombre
de globules blanc ou le nombre de
globules rouge la santé c'est ce qu'il a
dans le cœur dans la tête c'est le
moral les fait n'estce pas Catherine
c'est qu'à un moment l'opinion se
demande si l'homme ou la femme qui est
en charge des affaires de l'État est en
mesure de continuer à gouverner pré
c'est c'est la question mais vous ne
cherchiez pas à savoir vous savez pas
mais écoutez jusqu'en 92 80 jusqu'à bon
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'opération je dois
dire jusqu'à l'été 92 j'étais chargé
avec éisabeth Guigou de la préparation
de la campagne pour le traité de
Maastrich bon il m'avait dit par
téléphone la nuit je ne dors plus je
souffle moi je pensais a des calculs
renult ou oui oui oui il paraît qu'il
vous a confié lors du dernier réveillon
à laat vous le dites je souffre comme si
j'avais la guest moi
fin donc moi j'ai découvert comme tout
le
monde la veille de son opération
MarieClaire PAP sa secrétaire m'a
téléphoné pour me dire demain matin le
président entrera à l'hôpital c'est une
marque de gentillesse qu'il a eu à
l'égard de plusieurs d'entre nous pour
qu'on soit pas surpris et que
saviez-vous les uns les autres de la
double famille du président moi je
savais rien que le public va découvrir
le des obsèes c'estàdire Anne Pingot
c'est-à-dire Mazarine la fille vous
savez-vous mais je ne savais rien je je
d'abord je m je ne me mêle pas de la vie
intime des uns ou des autres lui-même
avait lui-même monsieur Favier explique
très bien il avait une façon de bon il y
avait ceux qui étaient au courant ceux
qui ne l'étaient pas et je ne cherchais
pas à mimisser dans son sa vie intime et
vous vous saviezcore la rumeur circulait
là aussi dans dans Paris dans le milieux
mais vous cherchez pas à enquêter vous
l'enquêteur non on pas fait d'enquête
sur la vie privée de François mitteran
qui ne m'a intéressé que mais non mais
en plus c'était une période où les
journalistes il y avaient un accord
Tacide pour ne pas parler de la vie pré
c'était pas la période d'aujourd'hui
d'abord il y avait pas de journaux
people pour reprendre les informations
et c'était pas seulement pour à propos
de mitan mais Mo quand j'ai fait quand
j'ai fait la biographie je savais que
Mazarine existait mais on metttait je
mettais mon point d'honneur à ne pas le
dire parce que je disais la vie privée
est privée mais je le savais bien sûr et
un jour j'avais été au Bon Marché faire
des courses et j'avais vu mestan dans un
magasin de chaussures qui acheté des
chaussures à Masar encore l'idée naïve
que la transparence est bonne dans
n'importe quelle condition je n'uris pas
appelé un photographe de mat pour venir
faire la photo parce que c'était une
autre pas vous dénoncez le procès qui
lui a été fait vous le qualifiez
durement le procès à propos de des
révélations pierre Péant sur les
relations avec Bousquet absolument même
Mazarine que je ne connaissais pas mais
que j'ai appris à connaître depuis qui
est une une jeune femme de très grande
qualité moral et intellectuel a dit dans
un interview je crois au Parisien voici
quelques semaines Bousquet pour Françis
mitan Bousquet était une connaissance
mais n'était pas un ami ça c'est ça la
vérité historique CIT une connaissance
ce n'était pas un ami arrivé de déjeuner
avec lui comme Jacques qui s'est trouvé
un jour par hasard ça aurait pu se
produire mais aurait pu ouais et vous
dites qu'il y a beaucoup de flatteurs de
la dernière heure qui avait pris la poue
des scampettes vous dites la dernière
heure mais on peut dire aussi de la
première heure non peut-être aussi ouais
et qui se qui courbait les chines devant
les les éventuels successeurs c'est
banalement humain oui quand le mur de
Berlin est
tombé il a le mur la chute a surpris
beaucoup de chefs d'État est-ce qu'il a
voulu retarder comme on l'a répéter et
empêcher la réunification de l'allemne
les polémiques sur la politique
étrangère de Méran on ceci d'intéressant
que d'abord elles reviennent sans arrêt
ce sont des polémiques politiciennes
franco-françaises elles ne tiennent
aucun compte de ce qu'on écrit les
historiens depuis ni des archives mais
les gens qui polémiquent ne lisent pas
les historiens manifestement d'allemand
de allemand entre autres mais sur
l'Allemagne sur la Yougoslavie sur le
Rwanda sur plein de sujets donc c'est
les mêmes choses qui comme des canards
sans tête qui qui circulent et ça
empêche des évaluations intéressantes et
sérieuses sur la la gestion des grands
dossiers internationaux parmi TER que
c'est polémiques bêtes envahissent tout
le terrain dans le F allemande c'est
peut-être la plus la plus sote de toutes
puisque mitan avait dit elmou schith dès
octobre 81 que Lurs était tellement
affaibli que d'ici peu d'années 15 ans
peut-être même 10 elle ne pourrait plus
empêcher la réunification et chmit tout
disait je voudrais y croire mais j'ose
pas y croire et on voit bien avec le
recul que toute la politique de mitteran
avec colle pendant toutes les années 80
c'est pas simplement l'amour de l'Europe
au sens abstrait c'est parce que il veut
que la France sobtiennent de l'Allemagne
avant la réunification le fait qu'on a
une monnaie unique et pas simplement la
zone marque qui va s'imposer à nous ce
qu' fait avec il a Russie d'ailleurs ça
donc ça explique toute cette on peut pas
dire un truc plus faux que de dire il a
pas vu il a vu il a vu comment il
fallait faire dans la gestion des choses
à chaud il était pas instantanément
d'accord avec col sur tous les points il
était souvent encouragé par gcher
ministre allemand d'ailleurs à essayer
d'obtenir de Cole des positions que Cole
ne voulait pas donné pour des raisons de
politique intérieure donc FRR c'est
incroyablement bér sur la question de la
frontière de PU
et développé c'était l'Europe et en même
temps il a mainten pas l'Europe au
Sensier c'est une France
Forte forte dans l'Europe forte c'est
pas simplement on s remis à l'Europe
parceon est trop fatigé le développement
des relations franco-allemandes la poign
deain à verd avec c'est pas mal comme
syle il y a un bus c'est pas le but
stratégique ça oui lors de son les
polémiques sont intéressant toutes ces
polémiques que je les considère comme
absurde par contre il y a des vraies
évaluations à faire par exemple pourquoi
son idée de confédération européenne qui
était très intéressante pourquoi est-ce
qu'il l'a lancé trop tôt pas trop tard
trop tôt sans préparation pourquoi il a
mis l'URS dedans pas les États-Unis ça
fait capoter le truc il a il s'est
planté sur certains point important mais
on peut pas en parler parce qu'on est
envahi par ces polémiques et lors de son
élection il passait pour un
antiaméricain il a démontré que c'était
pas tout à fait ça avec les trois
présidents
reaninton pas d'être pro antiaméric de
toute façon il a toute sa politique est
définie par une excellente formule on a
même parlé de golomitérandisme à ce
sujet ami allié mais pas aligné bon le
problème des Américains c'est qu'il ne
supporte pas que les Alliés soient pas
liignés il faut espérer que le temps
l'histoire donc permettra de comme le
dit de réévaluer tout ce qui concerne la
construction de l'Europe la politique
avec la gallemagne la yoslavie la
question du Rwanda quian c'est à qui ça
de toute façon dans les sondages quand
on demande aux Français leur avis dis
tout ces polémiques tourn en
circuit discuté encoreement de la
question
duine la présentation qui est faite de
tout ça est absurde absurde oui non
quand vous dites de Gaul mitteran quand
même jamais pendant les oui oui de Gaul
plus mitéran mais il y a pas eu critique
plus fondamentale du gaulisme que
mitéran surtout VO les institutions la
politique étrangère la défense il n
rallé la force nucléaire qu'en 78 et en
81 il disait la dissuasion c'est moi
alors qu'il n'avait jamais voté 84 84 84
non non non non c'est avec le le
programme commun il avait eu une
altercation avec les communistes qui
avait r la dissuasion c'est moi c'est
d'ailleurs vrai parce qu'il faut un
disurique enfin bref il disait ça qu'il
n'avait jamais voté un budget militaire
pendant 23 on on va retrouver François
mitan il est tout entier dans ses propos
sur le débarquement en normandiste un
anniversaire il avait à ses côté la
reine Élisabeth Bill Clinton helmoud
Cole ça vaut la peine lundi c'était
l'anniversaire du débarquement et samedi
c'était euh port mousth la réception de
dear d'Angleterre un brûle pour point
quel quel souvenir quelles images si je
vous demande quelques images vous gardez
çaile à dire je trouvais que la
cérémonie américaine avec
l'Amérique les États-Unis de ut à Beach
la première
celle qui avait le plus de force et
ensuite je garde l'image de la lumière
la belle tendre lumière du
soir dans pour les cérémonies
canadiennes et
polonais ce contraste était très
émouvant pu c'était
beau dans le
froid oui dans le vent nous on regardait
la télévision vous voyez viv cet instant
et sur ces lieux illustres vous vous
viviez l'instant est-ce que vous étiez
dans dans des songes dans des souvenirs
qu'est-ce que vous vous disiez
làci plages où tous ces
gens étai où étaient mort où avait pris
le risque de la mort en le
sachant vous pensez et je pensais en
même temps qu'il ait suffit de d'une ou
deux divisions curation allemande de
plus dans la région sur 70
km r les les les Alliés n'auraient pas
pu rés résister donc les lieux
inspiraient à la fois le souvenir la
réflexion sur ce qui s'était passé vous
disait il fait froid c'est long c'est
long j'ai pas trouvé j'ai trouvé que la
première cérémonie s'est passé pour moi
dansque deant
et je ne voulais pas avir des manteaux
des lainages excessifs à côté de Clinton
qui avait juste sa veste et pu moi aussi
hein mais à un moment donné j'ai je
disais j'ai eu tort bon enfin rien de
comparable nous étions là nous 50 ans
après
et dans le
bien-être les soldats qui étaient là 50
ans plusut tôt c une immense aventure un
drame terrible en même temps l'annonce
de temp nouveau en quoi il peut inspirer
encore aujourd'hui votre
mitéran la difficulté à mon avis que
nous rencontrons tous dans cette C
missions et dans beaucoup d'autres qui
vont suivre c'est de parler de ces
moments extrêmement intenses sans
nostalgie et mit était jamais
nostalgique hein il toujours projeté
dans le l'action dans l'avenir ou dans
l'histoire parce qu'il était capable de
gérer les choses immédiates en
s'inscrivant dans le dans un moment
historique donc ce serait être infidèle
à cet enseignement de vie encore plus
qu'un enseignement politique que de
s'enfermer dans une nostalgie simplement
commémorative et en même temps personne
ne peut dire qu'il est l'héritier ou le
descendant c'est trop vaste c'est trop
riche c'est trop divers mais il me
semble que tout le monde peut continuer
à puiser dans
la 15 en 15 ans par exemple le monde a
tellement changé si miteran revenait il
le reconnaîtrait pas mais il
s'adapterait il a déjà changé pendant la
période miteran parce qu'il a eu à gérer
ce basculement du monde qui est la fin
de la guerre froide depuis la guerre
jusqu'à la fin de l'URS pas la chute du
mur entre guillemets parce que c'était
une ouverture du mur en fait mais la fin
de l'URS fin 91 c'est là où ça change et
à partir de 92 on est dans ce fameux
monde global qui est une une effroyable
compétition de tout le monde avec tout
le monde donc ça a déjà commencé c'est
déjà souitérant que la France a dû
commencer à s'adapter à l'étape suivante
donc il serait pas surpris par ça ser
peut-être surpris par de grand choses
mais en tout cas il serait pas
nostalgique il serait
dansaction inspirer la nostalgie
mitérant si elle existe c'est une
nostalgie des des grands dessins des
grandes aventures collectives et notre
pays est ainsi fait qu'il a besoin
d'être tiré vers l'avant par des grands
projets des grands projets industriels
des grands projets technologi des grands
projets internationaux la construction
européenne de grands projets culturels
tout à l'heure Huber disait Goo
miterandien de manière oui parce que de
Gaulle aussi à un moment donné a proposé
au pays dans le domaine industriel
George Pompidou à sa manière aussi donc
c'est cela c'est il faut tirer le pays
vers de grandes aventures vers de
grandes mais est-ce qu'avec le temps
comme il le disait tout à l'heure
lui-même on on n'embellit pas les choses
on n'oublie pas ce qui a été des
querelles sur les affaires sur des tas
de choses naturellement que les images
c'est purure avec le temps mais il y a
un point personnellement où je trouve
que je regrette qu'il n'est pas voulu
bouger d'un d'un pouce c'est sur la
constitution moi je déplore je lu ai dit
plusieurs fois à ma manière je déplore
qu'il n'it pas voulu changer cette
constitution et il faut et il faut
reconnaître à l'actuel président le
mérite d'avoir été le premier président
de la République qui a osé ouvrir
entreouvrir ou ouvrir le chantier de la
rénovation s là-dessus avait un argument
imparable il disait que le Sénat était à
droite et l'assemblée était à gauche et
qu'il ne pouvait pas changer la
constitution sans l'accord du Sénat
parfaitement au moment où il était
popula VI de le faire avec emblé de même
couleur argument de mauvaise foi pardon
de le dire il pouvait parfaitement
organiser un référendum un référendum au
moment où
ilance qu'il avait dit que 7 ans c'était
trop long et il a fait 14 ans il était
le seul président avoir fait 14 ans
est-ce que la France a bénéficié
Catherine de ces deux mandats ces 14 ans
est-ce que la France en a bénéficié moi
je dirais moi je c'est pas une question
piège pour vous non c'est pas une
écoutez en a bénéficié moi je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup à dire est-ce que la
France s'est vraiment modernisé un peu
sûrement mais pas autant que on l'aurait
espéré moi je trouve que le deuxème
mandat de du président a été quand même
assez désevant c'était la période du
Nini la période de sa maladie enfin
euh moi je retiens quand on parle de
mitéran c'est un itinéraire
extraordinaire et un caractère
exceptionnel je crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui est né monarque qui a
toujours voulu être au-dessus des autres
et ce que disent tous ses proches et
tous ses collaborateurs il était
président avant même de l'être avant de
le devenir tous l'ont connu monarque et
président avant 81 la remarque sur le
deè ca qu'on entend souvent
rappelez-vous Catherine il est à
l'Élysée oui secrétaire général mastrich
c'est le deè mandat donc
l'accomplissement du travail fait en
préparation de la réunification
allemande qui se concrétise dans
Maastricht donc on n pas la zone Maré la
maladie c'est dans le 2è septcoup
important dans le SEP Valé giscardestin
qui ne manie ni la confidence facilement
et plus forte raison le compliment à son
avis sur celui qui fut son adversaire sa
victime et une fois son tombeur
valardestin et disait le caractère c'est
destiné en fait il disit ça au 5e siècle
avant jésusch donc faut prendre le
caractère des gens manifestement miteran
c'était pas l'exercice du pouvoir ça
nintéressait pas beaucoup quand je lui
ai transmis le pouvoir donc au printemps
81 je lui a donner des secrets ou des
confidences d'État importantes pour
l'exercice du pouvoir j'ai vu que ça
nintéressait pas vous vous dites dans le
livre il avait l'air
disprê oui lui il voulait se positionner
comme un homme qui a acc au pouvoir qu'
a symbolisé donc c'était c'est différent
ce qui fait n'appliquons pas la même la
même lecture la même identification à
des personnes de personnes caractèr
différents globalement avec le temps
vous avez plus d'estime que quand il
était en vie pas seulement un adversaire
mais qu'il était en vie qu'il vous avait
j'ai le même sentiment qu'il l'avait
remporté j'ai le même sentiment euh sa
politique a été néfaste pour la France
prenez les rubriques économiques
fiscales néfaste pour la France le
personnage était un personnage qui avait
la dimension présidentielle et même je
vais jusque là la dignité présidentielle
donc la dimension et la dignité
présidentielle même s critique tout le
reste Jacques Lang euh ce souvenir de
mitin est-ce qui peut avoir un effet
positif sur 2012 pour vos amis
socialistes je crois que si on veut être
si on veut être fidèle à un héritage il
faut être capable de de le transfigurer
de de le transformer mon sentiment c'est
que l'époque que nous avons vécu qui qui
lèue un certain nombre de de de choses
très positives on a évoqué l'Europe des
des grands projets d'univers c'est une
Europe c'est une époque d'hier en même
temps moi personnellement je rêverais
que nous soyons CAPA d'accomplir dans
les temps qui viennent une véritable une
autre révolution une révolution
territoriale pour enfin établir un
minimum de justice entre région riches
et régions pauvres une révolution du
savoir et Dieu sait qu'il y a beaucoup à
faire pour l'éducation pour la recherche
et une révolution démocratique et je
pense que sur ce planlà il faudrait être
extrêmement audacieux et sortir d'un
système qui en est fait quel que soit le
président demeure trop monarchique trop
lié à une personne et qui empêche par
conséquent le pays de respirer
profondément euh et aujourd'hui parmi
les vôtres on nentend pas cette ou cette
rupture que vous réclamez c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas de François miteran ni de
Françoise miteran ça viendra peut-être
ça viendra il avait dit lui-même je le
prends dans un de vos livres et celui de
Jacques Atali je n'aurais vraiment
réussi que le jour où un autre
socialiste que moi sera élu président de
la République c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à
2011 il a échoué parceil a pas eu suc
une formule c'est une formule c'est une
formule en même temps c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on mène un combat comme le sien
de longue durée cette longue traversée
au nom du socialisme on peut considérer
que la réussite c'est le jour où une
nouvelle alternance se produit et quand
même dans l'intervalle pour être juste
il a même eu la période JEP eu la
période l'alternance il a eu 5 années de
gouvernement jaqu Lang dans fragment de
vie partagée François mitaron
n'appartient pas au seul passé c'est une
pensée pour demain distribuer le livre à
certains de vos amis d'ailleurs on le
voit la plupart des postulants ce qui
veulent succéder à à à Nicolas SAR en
2012 se réclame revendique la lignée
mitterandienne que ce soit saolen royale
François Hollande Martin Aubri tous
rendent dommage à miteran on a
l'impression qu'il se met un petit peu
dans dans l' liignée dans le dans le
sierge de François mitan oui jusqu'ici
c'est un peu artificiel tout ça tout le
monde s'en réclame par qu'il y a pas
moyen de faire autrement estce qui puise
assez dans les enseignements
véritablement utiles on ne le sait pas
encore c'est pas encore démontré mais je
voudrais appuyer la remarque de Jacques
Lang sur la le gouvernement
juspin il y a quand même période Jospin
qui était un gouvernement très
populaire pendant toutes les périodes
non mais c'est pas pour ça on peut
parler de Jospin lui-même non nonement
il a été un très remarquable
premieruniste pour des raisons X et Y la
présidentielle ça n'a pas marché mais
c'est pas comme si c'était rien passé
depuis 1995 c'était justement celui qui
avait réclamé le droit ou le devoir
d'inventaire à l'égard du mitérandisme
ou mais c'était pas choquant après tout
quand on souligne des aspects qui ont
éché ou autres bon il une fausse
querelle làdessus bon vous entendre à
travers vos livres on VO bien qu'on en
finirait pas avec François mitteran plus
le temps s'éloigne plus les survivants
le voient plus grand l'histoire en tout
cas s'en est saisie peu à peu elle dira
qu'il a été quelle place il a occupé
quel progrès il a représenté pour la
France et quelle image il en a laissé à
tous nos voisins qui nous regarde 30 ans
après avec vous et je vous remercie
d'avoir été là avec nous pour ce
témoignage si proche de lui tel était
François mitteran aux jeunes générations
de prendre le relais en sachant qu'il ne
faut jamais se contenter
d'appréciation immédiate de celle des
contemporains pour avoir l'image exacte
de ce qui nous gouverne à leur égard le
temps peut-être pire et il arrive qu'il
soit meilleur ou même plus juste à vous
tous merci et à
bientôt
[Musique]